it's time to tuck yourself away with a
perfectly splendid new story in the
haunting series featuring spooky new
ghosts and murderous matriarchs
yupikai movie lovers i'm jan and in this
video we're diving beneath the surface
of bly manor to explain
everything about the ending the lady of
the lake the haunted house and its
ghosts plus what the final scene
really means obviously spoilers ahead so
take care
fly mana's original matriarch viola aka
the lady of the lake is at the heart of
this story and the eighth episode is
crucial for understanding the origins of
this season's mysteries
viola was a confident woman who contrary
to the norms of the time took charge of
her own affairs and refused to bow to
either her husband or the church
while her marriage was more of a
business arrangement she loved her
daughter dearly clinging to her tightly
as they slept together each night
and true to her possessive nature she
warned her child about those who might
seek control over the manner in the
future
it is you it is me it does
that moment is the origin of the phrase
that gives ghosts like peter quint the
permission they need to possess a living
person such as rebecca jessel or miles
that's you that's me josh we also see
violence jealousy and controlling traits
in her relationship with her sister
when she first notices a look between
perdita and her husband the beginnings
of a deadly lung disease manifest
later on she becomes violently jealous
of predator after she finds her dancing
with arthur and it's no coincidence that
peter quint acts in a similar way in his
relationship with rebecca
the lady of the lake stranglehold over
blimey manner is only broken in the
final episode when desperate to save
flora from a watery doom dany offers
viola permission to
live in her body
we don't know exactly why viola agrees
but it could be that dany's body offered
her the opportunity to escape her
endless cycle of purgatory or perhaps
what dany said
jolted some faded memory of the word
she'd said previously to her own
daughter
either way it seems that dany's will is
superior enough at that moment to keep
the lady of the lake repressed for a
while
the moment also breaks viola's spell
over all the other ghosts trapped at bly
who now disappear
and as viola accepts dany's invitation
the colour of this eye here
changes from blue to brown before this
moment
both dany's eyes were blue but from this
point on she now has one blue and one
brown eye
a mark of the beast now living in her
body
another detail that represents how dany
isn't entirely human any longer
is the doll that flora gives her when
they say goodbye are you sure you want
to give me this one
must have it it's you flora regarding
dany as a doll in some way
means deep down the little girl senses
something has changed in the au pair
because it contrasts sharply with what
she said to danny when she first arrived
at bly manor
is that me why no silly you're you it's
just a jolly
danny fears the spirit of violet inside
here and explains to jamie that it isn't
peaceful but is filled with rage she's
waiting
at some point she's gonna take me the
final episode's title the beast in the
jungle comes from the novella of the
same name by henry james in which a man
is seized by the fear that some
unknown catastrophe lies in wait for him
for dany
she understandably fears the beast
inside her however
unlike the book's protagonist danny and
jaime vow to make the most of whatever
time they have left
traveling then setting up a life
together one day at 10 is what we've got
it's what everybody's got when you get
dunked
and similar to viola dany discovers she
has a lot longer than she first thought
and she's able to live relatively
peacefully for over five years
by this time though dany feels that the
beast is drowning out her own feelings
more and more
and one night when she wakes up to
discover she's about to choke jaime she
understands the time has come when it's
too dangerous to stay another day
when jamie discovers danny has drowned
herself in the lake at bly manor she
begs dany to take her as well
but unlike viola's vengeful spirit
dany's soul refuses
because in contrast to the previous lady
of the lake dany's actions are motivated
by selfless love
jaime goes through life looking at
reflections in the hope that dany might
come back to her
when the older jaime played by carla
gugino goes back to her hotel room after
the wedding there's a hint towards a
happyish ending of sorts
she runs a bath and fills a sink with
water leaves her room door ajar then
falls asleep
as the camera cuts to behind jamie we
see what looks like dany's hand on
jamie's shoulder the clues being the
ring on her finger and the sweater
sleeve
my interpretation of this shot is that
dany isn't literally in the room but
rather as jaime fell asleep they were
both reunited in her
dream or memory while dany's spirit or
ghost remains a blind manner
the clue to this is what the storyteller
says to the wedding party about dany's
ultimate fate
she will merely walk the grounds of bly
harmless as a dove
for all of her days leaving the only
trace of who she once was
in the memory of the woman who loved her
most in the show we see that even living
characters like flora can experience an
old memory in a dream world of sorts
and i think that perhaps jamie is tucked
away in a memory with dany in this final
moment
if you like this theory about the ending
then leave a thumbs up and let me know
what you think in the comments below
another cool detail about this final
scene is that it cleverly links back to
the opening scene of the very first
episode
where the storyteller jamie wakes up
from her sleep at the hotel
which suggests that she has been
repeating this routine for several
nights with the hope of reuniting with
dany
and the way the end of the season in
effect loops back to the beginning
makes me think of the idea from hill
house that time isn't always linear but
can fold in on itself
i thought for so long that time was like
a line it's not like that at all
our moments fall around us like rain
vala is also the origin of the strange
time loops that many of bly's ghosts
find themselves trapped in
despite her prognosis by a doctor that
she would only have months left to live
her will to cling to life is stronger
and she remains alive a full six years
later
i do not go sick of her sister perdita
decides to kill her
however even then viola's will keeps her
spirit trapped in the realm of blind
manner locked away in the trunk of her
clothes and jewels that she had put away
for her daughter
here in this self-made purgatory viola
lives the same day
over and over sleeping waking and
waiting for someone with the key to open
the trunk
and she admitted her room was a dream a
construct
a lie preferred to the truth of the
trunk although viola's endless cycle is
broken when perdita opens the trunk
affording viola an opportunity for
revenge on her sister
sadness consumes her when she feels
abandoned by her husband and daughter
after they sell the house and toss the
trunk into the lake
but vila's will still holds her to this
world and she begins a new
unending cycle of sleeping waking and
this time
walking from her watery new home to her
daughter's bedroom
and back again her power even as a ghost
is the reason why everyone who dies on
the manor grounds is unable to leave and
they end up as ghosts stuck in a limbo
similar to hers
the pull of that next world ignored she
instead made her own gravity gravity of
will
that would change the terrain of bly
manor forever and it could be said that
her power even extends a little to the
nearby town of bly
something alluded to in the first
episode the people
here most of them they're born here they
die here
whole towns one big gravity well similar
to viola each of the other ghosts at bly
find themselves living in a loop of
their own construction after they die
they're able to hop around between
memories but they always seem to end up
returning to some defining moment in
their life
for peter quint he always finds himself
returning to a moment which he describes
as hell
because he has to repeatedly see his
mother come to try and blackmail him
the same person who enabled his father's
abuse of him and other children
let's think i'm in hell well where else
would you go
miss jaisal finds herself returning to a
moment where peter photographs her over
and over while she's wearing charlotte
wingraves fur coat
not this one not this one let me show
you
how beautiful you are rebecca hates this
memory because it's the time when she
decided to go along with peter's lies
against her better judgment and despite
mrs gross's warnings
this seminal moment ultimately led to
peter completely deceiving her when he
takes possession of her body
and drowns her so that she ends up stuck
with him in mrs gross's case she finds
herself returning to the moment when she
first met owen
her loop is not as unpleasant as peter's
or rebecca's perhaps because she doesn't
suffer the same regret
or guilt that peter or rebecca do for
their actions when they were alive
her loop can be disconcerting her at
times though because she's not aware to
begin with that she's dead but she is
essentially spending time with the
person who she grows to love and who
becomes her soulmate
a theme that becomes clear by the end of
bly manor is that the story we've seen
isn't just a ghost story but also a love
story same thing really
as creator mike flanagan told vanity
fair the show provides a new way to tell
a love story and by the end of the
season
it's really hard to differentiate
tragedy from romance
that sense of romantic longing for
someone who meant so much to us but
who's gone
really is the heart of any ghost story
and as we see over the season
bly manor includes many types of love
from healthy relationships to toxic
and guilt-ridden romances each with
their own power to either
exorcise or create new ghosts when dany
and jaime finally recognize their true
feelings for each other this moment
exorcises the ghost of her dead fiance
edmund which has been haunting her since
he died
the day after jaime and dany sleep
together dany is finally able to look in
a mirror without his ghost
staring back accusingly at her dany's
true love for jaime helps her let go of
her guilt over his death
as mike flanagan has said in the
haunting anthology series ghosts are an
expression of emotional wounds
and through her relationship with jaime
dany is finally able to heal her trauma
from edmund's death
likewise it's dany's selfless love for
flora and willingness to sacrifice her
own life when she invites viola to
possess her which exorcises all of the
ghosts
who have been trapped at bly manor in
contrast to dany and jamie peter quint
and rebecca jessel's relationship
is particularly toxic and filled with
jealousy deceit and manipulation
one of the manifestations of this is how
the pair take possession of miles and
flora often without their permission
something we see through the children's
strange behaviors such as miles
demanding to be given wine
and smoking and talking in a manner
untypical for a boy of his age
pisa is the principal toxic force in the
relationship and we see him abuse the
trust rebecca places in him when she
gives him permission to take control of
her body so that they can be together
forever
her stipulation was that they be equals
however without
asking for her consent he selfishly
drowns her in the lake trapping her as a
ghost with him forever at bly manor
a little detail foreshadowing just how
bad peter quint will end up being for
miss jaisal is when the song tainted
love plays in episode 3
just before he and henry interview
rebecca for the au pair job
and bound up with this idea of toxic
love is the theme of possession and
ownership
the two most destructive ghosts at bly
manor peter quint and viola
are obsessed with trying to control the
people around them
in fact in many ways peter doesn't treat
rebecca like an autonomous human being
with wants
needs and rights of her own rather he
treats her like property
he sees what he wants and takes it
without permission whether that's
draining henry wingrave's bank accounts
stealing jewelry and fur coats from bly
manor or taking rebecca's life forever
and the way peter manipulates people to
do exactly what he wants
is like a child playing with a toy or
like flora playing with her dolls as
mike flanagan says
however as dany explains treating people
like this is the antithesis of true love
people do don't they mix up love and
possession i don't think that should be
possible
i mean their opposites really love and
ownership when grown-up flora tells a
storyteller she's scared of losing her
forever person
jamie replies that they should enjoy
their time together and not worry about
that
and when that moment comes she can still
enjoy the memories of their time
together
and as i said earlier that's something
we see jaime do herself at the very
end of the season it's also something
the older owen talked about in his
speech at the rehearsal dinner in the
first episode
to truly love another person is to
accept that the work
of loving them is worth the pain of
losing them mrs gross proves this point
at the end when she selflessly decides
to leave the memory she's in with owen
to help him in the real world
be brave in death anna we both know
you're not so selfish
to remain hidden in the memory likewise
dany's lady in the lake refuses to drag
jaime down with her
and similarly in the end rebecca manages
to reject peter's manipulations and
helps protect flora by refusing to
possess her as well
the other main love story at bly manor
is between henry and charlotte the wife
of his brother dominic
after dominic discovers what's been
going on he and charlotte go on a trip
to india to repair their marriage
where they're tragically killed in an
accident the tremendous guilt that henry
suffered when he heard the news and the
knowledge that he was indirectly
responsible for their deaths gave birth
to his doppelganger ghost that night
and this ties in with what mike flanagan
has said that when we fall in love we
give birth to
a new ghost henry's antagonistic alter
ego ghost was a product of the guilt and
sadness he felt upon learning of the
death of the woman he loved
and similar to the ghosts of bly manor
henry seems to live much of his life in
a loop even though
he's still alive his brother might have
forbidden him from returning to bly
after his affair but henry's overbearing
sense of guilt
means he doesn't even leave his office
at night to go to his home in london
he also feels compelled to repeatedly
call blime manor making him the cause of
the silent calls at the house
coming up for a couple more videos on
blind manor including all the secret
hidden ghosts lurking in the house
plus another video with easter eggs and
more spooky details you might have
missed in the episodes
tap here for my haunting of blind mana
playlist or follow the link in the video
description
so what did you think of the haunting of
blind manor in its ending
and do you have any thoughts or theories
about dany or any of the ghosts or
characters in the story
leave your thoughts and ideas in the
comments below if you enjoyed this then
a thumbs up is hugely appreciated
tap left to watch my next blind mana
video or tap right for something else
you're sure to like
thanks for watching and see you next
time yupikai movie lovers